alors ici donc vous avez le salon ce
n'est pas une visite ordinaire
aujourd'hui les acheteurs potentiels
n'ont pas eu besoin de prendre de rendez
vous ils ont juste sonnés et ça c'est un
bon point pour les propriétaires ça
donne un dynamisme
parce qu'on a des biens à vendre et puis
ben voilà qu on met ça dans les mains
des agents immobiliers
mais on n'est pas vraiment acteurs nous
est tandis qu'avec une opération comme
ça on peut participer et ça met un petit
plus un petit coup de pouce aussi on
espère vendre dans un village où près
d'un logement sur quatre étaient vacants
en 2018
la première opération osée jussey l'an
dernier a déjà apporter de la visibilité
à la commune depuis on a multiplié par
quatre voire cinq le nombre de
transactions immobilières à jussey pas
forcément dû qu'à la journée aux essais
mais c'est cette opération qui a donné
un point de départ à une vraie dynamique
des transactions immobilières sur gc
avec près de 90 transactions
immobilières dans les 18 derniers mois
c'est sûr cela donne des idées aux
communes environnantes
l'opération osez c'est donc exporter afa
vernet et à amance parfois avec des
petites nouveautés
alors ici le vendeur aussi puisque là on
a conscience que la seule politique qui
consisterait à vouloir réutiliser le
centre village n'est pas suffisante donc
on souhaite avoir une offre
complémentaire entre du centre village
en un habitat ancien et de la
construction de cette maison mise en
avant par rose est juste l année
dernière à trouver preneur moins d'un an
après l'événement on est tombé sur cette
annonce
on l'a visité un peu sans penser
vraiment à l'acheter et puis on a eu le
coup de coeur
la propriétaire a même ouvert une
boutique dans jc osé ce n'est donc pas
que la vente de maisons
c'est aussi redynamiser les
centres-villes âge